you've got your start in the music
business yes why did you leave that or
were you asked to leave what happened
exactly I wasn't good at it I record
stores and then I eventually got hired
to work for MCA records mm-hmm uh where
I was a rep for MCA and I would go to
record stores and I would sell the
product and and it was the brass ring of
jobs I mean it was I thought I was
living a dream I was hanging out with
rock stars I was doing cocaine I was not
doing cocaine and I was I was hanging
out and John I was hanging out with all
the rock stars right I thought I was at
the the peak of the mountain and one
time and I took it very seriously and I
was cocky I was on the side of the stage
was that a Tiffany concert member
Tiffany sure remember Tiffany performing
malls and stuff yeah and then she made
the jump she was doing arenas yeah and
so I'm at the side of the stage I'm
enjoying a delicious pasta salad and II
and the this is not bad I wasn't my job
the opening act was on stage and it was
five kids in different colored track
suits now and I turned to somebody
eating this pasta salad oh who are these
guys and they said oh these are some new
group called the new kids on the block
and I said mark my words they'll never
make it by the time I was done with that
sentence they had action figures they
were the biggest stars in the world
right I wasn't good at my job
right what's yeah you were not good at
your and she was like was there ever a
band that you got behind that you
thought this band surely will nicer
naked eyes will be the next Beatles I
truly believe it you literally set me up
for failure
yeah they didn't know Jon Secada you
think naked ice is gonna fly well I just
wanted to see you struggle success
now rap I understand that you enjoy rap
which doesn't it I don't feel like you
would enjoy rap you say that I'm painted
as a guy my favorite man is Chicago I
love him and I love the horns you know
that Jerry that's fun with the saxophone
I love Chicago
Iron Maiden Styx journey I'm so I'm
painted with this white dude brush but I
love rap I am I loved people don't
expect that for me but I love it I
appreciate you bring it up
you